WOLFF DOBSON: Hi, I'm Wolff.
I'm the tech lead for
developer relations
for machine learning at Google,
which includes the Brain Team.
Brain Team's big
project is TensorFlow,
which is an open
source library that
builds computational
graphs and is
used for machine learning,
especially deep learning.
It's free.
It's open source.
You can download it now.
I strongly recommend it.
But I'm not going
to teach you to use
TensorFlow in five minutes.
So let's talk instead
about why you'd
want to use machine
learning in your games
besides that wonderful
talk that we just had.
Let me give you
five things you can
do with machine
learning with your game
right now from
easiest to hardest.
Step 0.
We're all engineers--
well, lots of us are.
So we're going to start with 0.
Use analytics to predict stuff.
So modern games can produce
all kinds of interesting data.
And if you're smart, you're
probably collecting some.
Things you can do
are like how much
is this player likely to spend.
Is this player likely to quit.
Is this player cheating.
Is this player being toxic.
These are all things
you can find out.
This is super basic
stuff that you
can do with TensorFlow
or any other tool kit.
And it doesn't even
have to be complicated.
A simple linear regression
or linear classifier
can help you get a boost
and understand your audience
better.
Step 1.
A little bit harder.
Let's grab some
open source models--
deep models-- and retrain them
to be useful to your game.
So Inception is
an award winning--
well, we have awards--
deep network that does
image classification.
Because of the contest
data, it's kind of
obsessed with dog breeds.
But it is really easy to
retrain that and classify images
with, actually, a fairly
small amount of data
by deep learning standards
just on your laptop.
We have code labs.
We have samples.
All kinds of stuff.
Think about the player
activity you want to see.
Think about hand gestures
in front of cameras.
Think about all kinds of stuff.
Graph some image data
and get classifying.
And if you don't like
image processing,
we have other open source
models to play with.
Parsey McParseface--
that is its real name--
explains the functional role of
each word in a sentence, which
gives you the ability
to find meaning
from words and speech and text.
Super neat.
You should totally check it out.
All right, a little bit
harder than retraining.
You can use neural networks to
give your game art some style.
In neural style
transfer, you're taking
advantage of deep neural
networks semantic understanding
of a picture as well of both
the scene and the style.
So you can apply the
style of one image
to the semantics scene
data of the other.
So in this case, we have
a creepy clown image
and we have a
beautiful seaside town.
With style transfer, you can
then apply creepy clown style
to seaside town.
You can do that with
all kinds of stuff.
Again, there's
open-source models.
There's open source
examples to do this.
Think how much fun
your artists are
going to have coming up
with all different ways
to blend pictures that
are drawn with art in 2D
and 3D models within your game.
And if you have a good
GPU, you can actually
do style transfer in real time.
This dog, Peekaboo, is
getting styled transferred
at varied amounts by different
amounts when using the sliders.
Now we're getting fun.
So step 3 is dream
up new content
for your game using
deep learning.
Most people probably run into
these weird recursive dream
models which come from sort of
running an image recognition
model backwards.
But unless your game
is entirely on acid,
you're probably going to need
something a little bit more
practical.
One example is actually
from the community.
It's a web engineer in Japan--
wanted to learn ML in TensorFlow
as his personal hobby.
So in a few months,
he was able to build
a deep convolutional generative
adversarial network to generate
arbitrary TV popstar faces
based on a database of other pop
stars.
Another totally awesome research
using adversarial networks
is downsampling photos of
people and then learning
the mappings between the
low resolution photos
and the high resolution photos.
So then you can edit
in low resolution
and generate high
resolution photos.
So in this image, ground
truth is on the left.
In the middle, you have you
have the low resolution version
and on the right, you have
the generated image based
on that low resolution image.
If you've got pixel
artists, they're
going to have a lot
of fun with this.
No time to explain
this at all, but as
another adversial
model that lets you
do neural editing of faces.
Quickly transform a
brunette to a blonde or male
to female with
just a few pixels.
There's a link there.
Check it out.
It's totally cool deep
learning research.
And again, if images aren't
your bag, you can do music.
Google has Project
Magenta, which
is an open source
project that uses
ML that takes the problem of
given n minus one notes, what
is the nth note.
You can train it on all kinds
of music from Radiohead to Bach
and use a recurrent
neural network
to generate new
music for your game.
And finally, step 4--
NPC control.
This is kind of the
elephant in the room,
if you think about it.
There's obviously been a lot
of super interesting work
from our neighbors in London
at DeepMind on AlphaGo.
There's some recent good
successes with poker.
I just read a paper about
using reinforcement learning
to play Super Smash Brothers.
Totally cool stuff.
One note of caution--
I think is absolutely
fascinating research,
but at least in the experiences
that I've had with it,
the danger is that
cameras in game
play kind of work against you.
That kid in a blue hat?
He has no idea how complicated
the neural networks
of the kids around him are.
Just zero idea.
He has got his head down.
He's focused on hopping.
You're going to find that
when you start applying
deep learning to NPC control.
Yet super excited
about this anyway.
There's going to be a lot of
things you can do with this.
Learning animation
parameters from video data.
There's interesting
work going on here.
Player dropout and take over.
If you have players playing some
online game and they disappear,
we need to replace with
a copy of them that's
learned from their behavior.
Sidekicks, dialog generation.
You know, we're generating
music in the previous example.
There's no reason why you
couldn't apply that to dialogue
although obviously, it's a lot
more semantically complicated.
Custom content
generation for opponents
and levels and stories.
The world is your oyster.
And speaking of oysters,
here's where we have ours.
TensorFlow.org is
where you can find
tutorials and code and
the TensorFlow framework
for doing deep learning.
We have a Udacity course.
I strongly recommend--
if you're interested
in this-- the Stanford
CS231 class on GitHub.
They have an
amazing introduction
to how machine learning works.
And we also just
have a video series
that introduces the basic
concepts of machine learning.
And there we are.
Thank you very much.